is the 2 000 mac studio really worth  over double the price compared to the m1  macbook air well today i will give you  guys my honest feedback after two weeks  of use so let's go ahead and jump in  overall i was really surprised by most  of these projects and how much of a  difference this makes now of course if  you're looking at the base model for  6.99 that's all you can afford this is  going to be an insanely good system but  once you start upgrading you start  adding more storage you start caring  about the ports this is where the mac  studio really comes into its own and i  think for a lot of you guys if you keep  your system for three years four years  five years i would definitely spend the  extra money now and now if you can't i  would also say if there's any way you  can wait for about a half a year and  wait for the m2 mac mini  with the new processor i would do so  because it's going to get a lot of extra  benefits  it will be worth the wait